hello and welcome it's June 19 2023
we're going to have a presentation and a
discussion with Maxwell ramstead and
Mala aburassen here so thank you Maxwell
and Mal for joining looking forward to
your presentation setting some of the
context and then thank you to all of our
guests you'll have an opportunity to
introduce yourself and give some
background when you first uh give
Reflections so
onto the slides Maxwell
excellent well maybe we now and I can
just briefly reintroduce ourselves for
uh those of us watching at home
um so hey folks uh my name is Maxwell
ramstead I am the uh director of
research at versus AI
um I am a scholar in the tradition of
active inference and an expert on the
free energy principle
um yeah and now would you please
sure so my name is I work at versus with
Maxwell and director director of product
for research and development but I'm
also doing a PhD in cognitive Computing
I worked in social sciences and in
artificial intelligence in the
artificial intelligence field and I've
specifically tried to apply active
inference to more socially grounded
questions and sometimes more abstract
and representational questions
diving all the way down to the
philosophy that can be attached to it
thank you Val
um so yeah I'm very pleased to present
this work uh today uh Mal and I will be
discussing our new pre-print
um called the inner screen model of
Consciousness and it is about it is
basically an application of the free
energy principle to the uh problem uh
the conundrum of Consciousness
um so uh just to give a little bit of
background and now I'll just be walking
through the slides if at any point you
want to uh jump in and you know add
complete correct uh please feel free to
do so
um so the uh this is work uh that
started in late last year
um and continued throughout the year
it's preoccupied us quite a bit actually
uh over the last while
um now and I are the lead authors on
this uh what has now become a series of
papers uh with uh one more pre-print
coming out hopefully before the end of
the months and another
in the works hope Pro hopefully before
the end of the year uh with the same
Core group of authors uh so obviously uh
Mao uh as well as Adam saffron Alex
Kiefer Brandon Klein Chris Fields uh and
Carl friston
um and uh the follow-up papers uh
include a bunch of other authors uh so
we've been uh working with some uh
pretty cool folks on this uh folks
listed here uh and others
um yeah and so the overall Lane across
the uh two or three papers uh is to
present something like a minimal
unifying model uh of Consciousness
premise on the free energy principle in
the paper that we're discussing today uh
we are presenting as I was uh intimating
a moment ago a model of Consciousness
that follows directly from applying the
free energy principle to well understood
human neurophysiology
um the take-home message of today's talk
is that uh well let me take one step
back there has been a lot of discussion
in the literature over the last decade
uh about whether the free energy
principle has anything uh unique to
teach us about Consciousness and there
have been responses Pro and Contra
um and I think that the question up
until recently was just unsettled uh we
would like to suggest a positive
response to that question
um and so as such one of the take-home
messages is that actually yes a model of
Consciousness can be directly derived
from the free energy principle uh
applied to explain
neuroanatomy and um I guess the the kind
of technical message the technical part
of the takeaway is that Consciousness
has or
um is isomorphic to a math a nested
holographic mathematical structure
um so uh this sounds like a mouthful
might sound a little crazy
um we are going to unpack this uh
presently
um I'll take some some now did you want
to add anything to that
no all good excellent
um so uh the original paper uh that we
wrote turned into like a 24
000 word monstrosity of a paper uh and
it was uh elephant elephantine both in
the sense that it was very large
um and also in the sense that of the uh
Sufi parable of the Blind Men and the
Elephant what we're trying to do is in
some sense
um identify a parsimonious mathematical
structure that underwrites the different
accounts of Consciousness that have been
developed based on the free energy
principle
I'll spare you the original paper
structure
um I said a moment ago that we uh we're
developing a minimal unifying model this
is a notion that was proposed by our
friend and colleague Vania Visa uh uh I
believe a few years ago now in 2020
um and Vanya at the time was noticing
um that well the field of Consciousness
studies is replete with a bunch of
different models and theories
um and there seems to be no end in sight
to the multiplication of these theories
and uh you know the idea is maybe what
the field needs is not one additional
you know n plus one Theory Of
Consciousness but rather a minimal
unifying model uh by which Vanya means a
model that specifies only necessary
properties of Consciousness so this
doesn't come with like a strong
sufficiency claim really like what are
the kind of rudimentary building blocks
that are necessary for Consciousness in
general
um this model would have determinable
descriptions that can be made more
specific so it's kind of a base model
that can be expanded to cover different
varieties of conscious experience and
finally that you know it's minimal and
unifying in the sense that it integrates
a current approaches to Consciousness in
no small part by highlighting their
common assumptions
um so you know kind of pointing to a
least common denominator of all existing
accounts and so what we have tried to do
in this paper is to uh well in this
series of papers is to do uh engage in
this analysis and this uh mummy analysis
if you will for theories of
Consciousness uh premised on the free
energy principle directly so it's worth
quickly discussing the free energy
principle uh I'm almost embarrassed to
do this at the Active inference
Institute uh but it's always worth going
through this very quickly
um so there's a standard distinction in
physics that one can leverage between
Dynamics mechanics and principles the
free energy Principle as it says on the
tin is a principle
um so principles are kind of the
foundation of a hierarchy of theory
building in science at the as it were
top of the hierarchy uh our formal
descriptions of behavior what are known
as Dynamics so if you're applying
dynamical systems theory to understand
uh you know the time evolution of some
system you're in the realm of Dynamics
uh arguably folks like Kepler and
Galileo were also in the realm of
Dynamics so I see some empirical
phenomenon and I produce a formal
description of that behavior mechanics
comes into play when we move from Kepler
and Galileo to Newton when we move from
merely describing some Behavior to
providing equations of motion that allow
us to explain why that behavior has the
particular shape that it does
um so uh you know classical Mechanics
for example gives us an account of
gravitational force and explains why
orbits are shaped the way they do so if
if Galileo and Kepler just noticed the
shape of orbits and provided a formal
description of them Newton explains
where that shape comes from in some
sense
and principles in turn explain where
mechanics come from
so classical mechanics come from the
principle of least action or stationary
action which uh very roughly speaking is
the principle According to which uh and
no more or no less energy is used than
necessary to perform some physical
movements that kinetic and potential
energies balance out such that the true
Paths of the system through its state
space are those for which that balance
equals zero the principle of least
action uh explains where uh classical
mechanics comes from in some sense and
similarly uh the free energy principle
is at the basis of another kind of
mechanics uh that is becoming known as
Bayesian mechanics you can think of the
300g principle as having the same
relation to Bayesian mechanics as the
principle of least action has the
classical mechanics and Bayesian
mechanics is the physics of
probabilistic beliefs so
um it's a physics that connects the uh
properties of the system that you're
considering the physical properties of
the system so for in particular the
information
entropy of uh states of the system to
the uh thermodynamics sorry to the in it
connects the thermodynamic entropy of
the states of a system to the
information entropy of the beliefs that
a system has about the the uh systems to
which it is coupled here A probabilistic
belief uh means a probability density uh
uh in a very general sense we're not
assuming some kind of contentful notion
of belief like you might find in uh
philosophy really this is about kind of
a tracking relation but we'll get that
to that in uh actually just a few slides
there are two main formulations of the
free energy principle in the literature
the classical and the quantum both rest
on this apparatus of the Markov blanket
uh the Markov blanket definitionally is
uh the degrees of freedom that separate
but couple uh two systems or rather two
things within a larger system it's
effectively a statistical boundary uh
that allows us to say that well given
this boundary the inside is independent
of the outside
um the way that we uh Express the
dependencies so taking one step back
quickly this is a dynamic systems
approach to uh to cognition to a
self-organizing systems and to physical
systems more generally uh it is
dynamical systems approach in the sense
that we're you know using the tools of
dynamical systems theory to examine the
time evolution of a system it's
trajectory in its state space and in
this context a generative model is used
to encode the relations of dependents
that obtain in the time evolution of the
system so this is important and I've
been uh you know uh the kind of making
this point uh like uh maybe Ad nauseam
for the last I guess half decade but the
generative model is not a model that you
have in your head
it is a uh it is a statistical model
that represents the conditional
dependence structure of the entire
system that you're considering so this
is an an environment agent system uh in
the broadest sense
um and uh the free energy principle says
that if a specific sparseness structure
obtains uh so if things are disconnected
in a special way uh then uh it'll look
as if uh the subsets that are
disconnected are tracking each other
um so uh more technically uh we
partition our system into particles uh
particles are basically internal States
shrouded behind their Markov blanket
where the Markov blanket is composed of
sensory States and active States sensory
states are affect affect internal States
but are not affected by the internal
States and active States affect external
state but are not affected by external
States uh this uh kind of this
separation of causal dependence uh and
this structure uh intervening between
the two bulk
uh subsets of the system is really
critical
um the free energy principle says if if
my generative model which encodes all of
the dependencies of the system if my
generative model contains a Markov
blanket in the sense that we just
defined then we uh are basically
licensed in our interpretation of
internal States as basically tracking
external states where tracking has a
specific mathematical definition in this
context tracking means to encode the
parameters of some probabilistic belief
about external States so to the extent
that we want to call this representation
we should note that this is not a
representation in the typical
teliosemantic sense of having some
internal States track some external
features
um it what we're what we're saying is
that basically if I have a Markov
blanket then my internal states are
basically shaping a belief about the
external world and I think that's really
critical to understand
um and this is where the inference and
the modeling that comes from this kind
of tracking relationship formally
speaking is approximately inference so
basically
in a nutshell the free energy principle
says in our physical universe as we
understand it with the the usual
mechanics running in the background
right classical relativistic Quantum and
statistical uh if boundaries exist in
the physical system then the bulk across
the boundary is going to be tracking
whatever is beyond the boundary so in a
nutshell this is what the free energy
principle says now I noticed you put
some stuff in the chat would you mind
using your voice to complement that yeah
I was just saying that this part that
you were just explaining often seems
kind of as etheric to people
um but it's critical to understand the
sparseness of the coupling because then
you kind of start understanding where
perspective comes from and if you have
perspective you also have uh the the
capacity to um to assess causality
um starting from a point and extending
outwards to something else and this is
true from any so that's that's what I
wanted to add
thank you Mama I think that's useful
addition
um yeah so this is the classical
formulation of the free energy principle
um there is a new hit funky uh uh
formulation that has become available
over the last half decade due to uh
Chris Fields uh Jim glazebrook and their
colleagues these so-called Quantum
information theoretic formulation of the
fep fear not this doesn't appeal
directly to Quantum Mechanics rather it
appeals to uh the tools that have been
used to extend information theory in the
context of quantum mechanics which allow
you to calculate like all sorts of funky
wave equations and propagation operators
and all that we don't have to get into
the details basically it's just a way to
reframe what I just said so what I just
said is if there's a boundary in my
physical system then the things across
the boundary will look as if they're
tracking each other another way of
saying that is
um well this boundary is a kind of
screen uh green uh takes on a particular
sense in Quantum Quantum information uh
Theory uh we don't necessarily have to
get into the details of it but basically
um you can think of these degrees of
freedom that couple the two systems as a
kind of probabilistic surface and you
can think of the bulk across either side
of the boundary
as in alternation reading and writing
information onto the blanket
so uh any Markov blanket whatsoever can
be construed as a classical information
Channel or a screen and in effect uh all
of the classical information that you
need to describe the way that things
across the boundary so the so-called
bulk of the system couple to uh one
another is contained on the boundary it
encodes the classical information that's
necessary to describe the couplings uh
within the system
um so uh we this is the this is
holography not in the sense of um this
is the Hologram not in the sense of
holography although we might discuss
senses in which these things are
intertwined
um we're we're using the word hologram
in the sense of the holographic
principle uh from physics the
holographic principle is a principle
that was originally uh discovered in the
context of black hole thermodynamics and
what it basically tells us is
necessarily from the point of view of an
external Observer some bulk in in
physical space can only contain as much
information as can fit onto its surface
uh so this Echoes what we were just
discussing about Markov blankets the
physical reason is that if a bulb
collapses into a black hole
um and the bulk contained any more
information than could be fit onto its
boundary uh then we would basically be
losing information and that would
violate uh the conservation of classical
information also known as the principle
of unitarity in quantum mechanics which
basically says that information is never
lost
um so uh we're using the word hologram
in that sense this is different from the
sense of hologram uh I mean everyone has
seen like the Hologram of Tupac or does
that make me look seem old at the Super
Bowl a few years ago or maybe Pokemon
cards maybe that also makes me seem old
now I don't know what the kids are doing
but you've seen like red baseball cards
and stuff like that with different
superimposed like picture layers that
become visible as you move that's not
the sense of hologram that's at stake
although maybe so we'll get to why but
let's we'll focus on the Hologram
theoretic formulation
so to summarize in the Hologram
theoretic hologram holographic principle
version of the free energy principle the
quantum information theoretic version of
the principle all of the classical
information that I need as an external
Observer to characterize the coupling
between two subsystems of a larger
system exist on the boundary
um and that's a pretty remarkable
physical fact
and a few years ago uh Chris Fields Jim
glazebrook and Mike Levin proposed that
maybe uh this kind of uh information
concentrating bottleneck architecture uh
also has application to uh Consciousness
in the form of an internal screen so the
idea was that you know the the
information that I bring to bear to
parse my sensory stream and make sense
of what is constantly bombarding me it
has to live somewhere
and so uh the idea is well it lives in
this inner screen so you basically have
an external Markov blanket which is a
Markov blanket just in the usual sense
and then
um the idea is well within the set of
internal States
um that uh are kind of partitioned off
from the organisms due to the organisms
Markov blanket then you would have an
internal Markov blanket structure within
those internal States
um this is prediction six from the great
paper minimal physicalism internal
awareness requires internal boundaries
and there's this interesting connection
to integrated information Theory I'm I I
am agnostic with respect to IIT so we're
not going to go there today but for
those of you who are interested this
kind of inner loop mechanism seems to
generate positive integrated information
so there's an interesting connection
there
um before I move on to neurophysiology
I'll hand things over to Mao if you you
wanted to add anything yeah actually it
was literally about to type something um
that this is actually also connected to
some Neo materialist formulations of
um folding onto onto itself so maybe
this is something worth digging into a
little later in the talk
awesome uh then we shall and I I believe
that Ali is also a co-author uh on the
paper and we have him so uh
Congratulations by the way on the
pre-print I I saw it released and Mao
has told me about it I'm really happy to
see uh such serious uh philosophical
work being done with the free energy
Principle as the basis I think you
should be very happy with the end result
and proud of but uh now uh let me get
back to uh my monologue
um so our uh rather uh our now and my uh
diet it's not really a dialogue it's
sort of like a I don't know how to call
it anyway
um
I'm thinking in French I have the words
in French I promise
um so
um now that we've you know reviewed in a
very much too short way to brutally fast
fashion uh the free energy principle and
its core formulations uh we're now going
to derive a model of Consciousness by
applying it to the known neurophysiology
of the brain are you ready
you buckled up okay good
um so uh we have just said that the fep
can be used to model things that have
boundaries I submit to you that the
brain is a thing with boundaries and
importantly a lot many several internal
boundaries
um so in particular we know that the
brain has a very sparse structure
um so you know if you think of uh just
the raw numbers right there are roughly
on the order of
150 160 billion neurons in the brain
um but each neuron only makes about uh
you know something like a five I want to
say five figures because I've spent uh
so uh 10 10 to the uh five uh
connections right so like roughly like I
think that
my you know my neurophysiology is a bit
far behind me but it's something on the
order of like a few thousand to maybe
tens of thousands of connections per
neuron so obviously if you just think
about it most neurons are not connected
to each other not directly
and furthermore the brain has a
hierarchical structure and when you
think about it what is a hierarchy a
hierarchy is a sparse connectivity
structure right so if you think about a
hierarchy of connectivity what having a
hierarchical structure means at the end
of the day this isn't some statement
about power dynamics where things at the
top of the hierarchy are more important
than things at the bottom your cortical
neurons don't drain more juice uh than
you know other uh parts of the brain the
neurons in those parts uh no what we're
talking about is a regular sparse
pattern of connectivity where I only
make connections to the layers directly
below me
and to the layers directly above me what
I want to suggest now is that you can
understand the sparseness
as a set of nested Markle blankets and
that's going to do a lot of heavy
lifting for us
um so the discussions here are based on
two papers uh one by uh fields and
colleagues called neurons as hierarchies
of quantum reference frames it's really
cool I recommend it uh and also a paper
by inesh ipolito myself and our
colleagues on Marco blankets in the
braid so this is going to be a much too
short summary of those discussions but
basically you can start with individual
neurons and then
um you know talk about uh their Markov
blankets
um to bring it back to something that I
was saying earlier but that I didn't
emphasize while we were going through
the slides the Markov blanket identifies
dynamical dependencies not necessarily
physical boundaries so it's a
statistical boundary it's not
necessarily like the boundaries of a
wall like a cell in the case of
formalizing individual neurons with
Markov blankets we would associate the
postsynaptic conductance with the
internal States the post-synaptic
voltage with the active States the
pre-synaptic conductance to external
States and the pre-synaptic voltage to
sensory States
you have some equations of motion that
tell you uh how each of these quantities
change and what they depend on and
you'll notice that this has the uh the
dependency structure of a Markov blanket
where the internal states only depend on
uh sensory active and internal States
um the active states only depend on
internal States and so on so it respects
the dependency structures uh that we
were discussing a bit earlier where
again you know the sensory states can
only depend on other blanket States and
external States and so on so here we
have a nice Dynamic Markov blanket that
we carve around our neurons and then
there are two directions that we can go
we can
Ascend the scales uh towards uh you know
canonical micro circuits and then uh you
know cortical columns uh individual
brain regions brain whole brain networks
and so on and at each of these
successive scales of self-organization
you can similarly identify uh Markov
blankets
uh if you want to uh uh discuss this in
more detail uh you can go see uh the
paper by inesh and myself and colleagues
um and you can also go from the
individual neuron down uh towards
um gated channels towards uh steinapses
uh dendrites and the uh Soma so the body
of the cell all of these things have
successive markal blankets and so all
throughout the brain's uh organization
at the different scales at which itself
organizes you have this nice structure
of nested Markov blankets of Markov
blankets of Markov blankets
um so that's one clear immediate sense
in which there are these blankets and
you know you you can start to think of
these blankets as screens uh in the way
that we uh just uh we're talking about a
slightly more illustrative example of
what we're talking about here is that
the martial blankets and predictive
coding this is a figure pretty typical
in the predictive coding literature what
it tells you is that the brain has
a series of uh levels or layers where
superordinate layers are basically
passing predictions about sensory input
onto onto subordinate layers and
subordinate layers are shuffling
prediction error back up to the
superordinate layers this is uh probably
like you know I'm almost embarrassed
again to discuss this at the Active
inference Institute I'm sure everyone is
quite familiar with these things already
the the novelty that we are introducing
here is to say well each of these layers
is connected to each other via a Markov
blanket
um and so that's I think like a key
Insight is that each of these layers has
internal States and communicates two
other layers through what you can
formalize as a Markov blanket so you can
understand at any given scale
of brain activity you can understand the
different levels of message passing as
successively nested screens
the cool thing is that what you know
what each of these screens is doing in
some sense is coarse graining the uh
stuff in the screen below so in some
sense each screen is kind of implicitly
contained in the following one and what
you end up having is a kind of nested
structure of screens of screens of
screens of screens which is uh I mean
pretty cool we recover as you'll note in
this figure the
um the inner screen hypothesis each of
these uh you know this is probably a
better way to visualize it you have to
at the left the uh out uh the kind of
external Markov blanket of the organism
it is uh segregating or carving out a
set of internal States and what we're
saying is these internal states have a
layered level level structure a sparse
structure that we can formalize using
nested Markov blankets
um and like I was saying each screen
successively coarse grains uh the next
screen and this gives some flesh to this
notion of contextual Computing this idea
that really what the brain is is an
organ of context where each layer is
providing context to the layer below and
where each layer is attuning to
increasingly higher order uh slower and
more
physically widespread regularities
um
so uh one thing that we're proposing
here uh which is a novel hypothesis that
we intend to test empirically over the
next few years is that this architecture
has two special layers in some sense
there are two uh you can think about it
as right only layers so if you're
thinking about the stack
um the absolute well the the per the
sensory periphery or the sensory bottom
it only sense in one sense can only
write in One Direction it can only write
into the system
um and the topmost level
um can only write downwards and this is
a key architectural feature one thing to
point out is that in the paper we
Associated uh the topmost level to
structures like the hippocampus we don't
need to suggest that the hippocampus is
uniquely the top uh of this hierarchy
rather there is probably a whole bulk of
structures that uh basically do do not
cannot any longer be coarse grained so
you kind of have like an executive level
pop and what's particular about this top
is that it can only write down into the
stack so it's its function really is to
be about and monitor the other layers of
the stack implementing a form of covert
action
and which trickles down uh throughout
the stack so
um now I saw you write some stuff uh
would you like to that yeah so I think
one of the things that's important to
highlight is why some things can only
write up and some things can only like
write down
um and what this means for irreducible
the irreducible market linkage which is
the part where if uh where our
experience happens uh because there's a
counter that and and some future
questions that are going to happen that
relates to Super structures and then why
don't we experience the consciousness of
a superstructure so I think it might be
important to dig into that a little bit
absolutely
um thank you uh so yeah uh to summarize
then uh there are basically two right
only layers uh as you ascend the layers
which are successively coarse graining
each other uh there is an irreducible
screen that can't further be coarse
grained uh we believe that this
corresponds to something like a
naturalized homunculus and we're calling
this perspective it with an intentional
provocation
we're calling this perspective
neocartesian
um in the sense that uh yeah we we may
have in some sense uh identified the
processes that make it seem as if there
was something like a homunculus
obviously uh we're not or maybe not
obviously it's worth saying we are not
um falling into the homunculus fallacy
because we're not claiming that the
topmost layers perceive themselves
so the buck stops with the top layers uh
and the top layers can can only perceive
themselves vicariously by acting through
other layers
um and you know we we associate this
action of layers of internal Markov
blankets on each other with attention in
particular and other neural modulatory
effects
um so I mean the overall picture is one
where Consciousness is intrinsically
related to overt and covert actions uh
to the overt uh acting and sensing
associated with the external Marco
blanket and with the covert actions that
are being deployed within the stack and
in particular that are issued by the
very top uh set of levels as I said this
is not necessarily a strict hierarchy it
could be a hierarchy with several
different tops but this integrated top
structure we believe uh could be
associated with a naturalized homunculus
I'm going to skip through uh the rest
and thank you for your attention
uh unless now one wants to add something
just one thing is I think to put it in
in simpler terms as well
the two layers that can only write can't
store memories because that's right
memories is not
um it's not just an encoding it's a
process of
um of retrieval and it requires
interactions between different levels
which is why the lowest levels are only
interacting with things which are
external and therefore can't necessarily
store and we can't like make direct
interactions with anything else within
the The Entity itself and the highest
level as well so there's no memories
being encoded at these two levels which
is why they're right only and not um
yeah I think that that helps a little
bit
thank you yeah I would agree
um so uh so thank you all for your
attention thank you in particular Dan
for the invitation it's always great to
be at uh the idol a double I and uh yeah
we uh looking forward to this discussion
I think Daniel said he wasn't going to
uh to do too much um
um animation so uh if people have are
you gonna do uh are you gonna do any
facilitation at all then
yeah
okay so uh thanks Maxwell and Mao for
the amazing talk
um there are so many interesting things
to dig on in this paper I don't know
even where to start but I do have one
question too actually in particular
so uh does this in-screen model imply a
kind of Proto and psychism or a more
restricted bio psychism I mean do you
think the type of nested holographic
structure uh described by the model only
exists in biological systems and
regardless of the answer would you think
that it generalizes to larger systems
comprising these systems like
populations and colonies and so on
maybe I can take a quick stab at that
um so we uh we think that
um the free energy principle itself
commits you to a kind of um I don't know
what the right word is we're kind of
we're writing a paper now uh we're
struggling with the exact coinage but
it's something it's not quite a pan
psychism it's it's a pen
representationalism or a pen tracking
ISM that you'll allow me to absolutely
disgusting uh neologism
um basically what the fpp implies is
that anything that has a boundary is it
looks as if it's tracking what's beyond
the boundary so at a very basic level
the fep kind of licenses this talk about
anything so anything whatsoever looks as
if it's tracking uh what's across the
boundary by virtue of existing
um so you know at a very basic level if
I see a rock outside I know that you
know it's not a thousand degrees Celsius
outside right like the the fact that
like a rock has a specific structure
entails something about its environment
uh likewise I can see uh you Maria you
are not wearing a winter parka and I can
uh you know infer from that that it's
probably room temperature around you and
not like you're not somewhere in
Antarctica or wherever else so uh this
kind of basic tracking relationship
applies to everything what we've tried
to do in this paper is to start you know
starts spelling out more explicitly what
the difference is between uh you know
just rocks and rock stars in some sense
like what what is the special kind of
structure that you need to add to the
Markov blanket and what you'll notice is
that you get Consciousness by making
this the overall structure more sparse
so as as you make it as you you as you
make more of the connectivity zero you
get all of these weird things that pop
up one of which is we think like this
this Consciousness structure
um malice thought about this prop maybe
more than I have so I'd be curious to
get her perspective
well so I know that people are a little
bit um wary of pan psychism so we
usually add the term Proto in front of
it uh and so the idea is that we have to
deconceptualize what Consciousness means
and oftentimes what we mean is something
that resembles what humans do
uh and we have to be a little bit if we
take our formalism Consciousness can
become emergent at the scales
where humans are where but but it
doesn't mean that it doesn't exist at
lower scales where uh the inertia or the
entropy generated by policies is um is
lower so if you think of a rock
um
its policy is pretty much
maintain bonds you know I mean like
there's nothing else the scale at which
some kind of thing
exists and changes is much different
than you deciding to have coffee but in
in effect your cells could be something
that we could consider exist closer to
something that Iraq does and even lower
uh just the proteins that make up your
system so
um if we understand that there is
nestedness
um and that the the conscious process
happens once you have this capacity to
to exchange information across layers
anything that has this stacking of
layers in a nested fashion is in effect
um
proto-conscious but
we have to be very very careful about
what we load into the the term conscious
I think is is mainly the question
I'm I'm sharing my screen here this is
from a paper on path integrals
particular kinds and strange particles
uh so it is a typology of different
kinds of Markov blankets uh and
different kinds of particles
um so something like a rock it still has
a Markov blanket but it's it's Markov
blanket is not partitioned into sensory
and active states there are no states
that have this property that the active
states have that they affect the
external world that are not affected by
it in return
a rock just has sensory States if I kick
a rock unless it's Radioactive It's not
going to act on me it's just going to uh
it only has the inference part of active
inference it's only kind of changing his
State as a response to the forces that
are acting on it
um active particles are particles that
have both sensory and active States and
you might think for example of a cell
uh a cell it has this kind of structure
um particles like ourselves
um have additional sparseness in the
Markov blanket in particular what we
call strange particles
um do not the internal states of strange
particles do not have direct access to
the active states of strange particles
and therefore they need to be inferred
and this is what gets you planning at
the end of the day a strange particle
can only exist in uh by kind of
inferring itself into existence
precisely because there is there are no
direct connections between the active
and the internal States so as you remove
uh connectivity
from the overall structure right uh here
from here to here you're adding
sparseness from here to here you're
adding sparseness as as you make the
system more and more sparse you get more
and more interesting Behavior to emerge
uh from the system and you know you can
think of the topmost uh structure that
we were describing as an instance of
like this broader architecture uh where
the topmost layer doesn't have direct
access to the active states of the
system and therefore it kind of has to
go through the entire bulk of the system
to infer itself into existence
so there's a few hands up uh I don't
there's no um it's not on Google where
you can see the people who share it oh
okay so Ali I think you raised your hand
first
uh yes thank you again for your crystal
clear and really Illuminating uh talk uh
I I've written down three uh questions
but maybe I'll begin with uh probably
the most basic and uh naive one uh so uh
in some of the earlier literature on
active inference and the fvp uh there
was this emphasis on distinguishing
between generative process and
generative model
but in this paper uh in figure one which
you also shown in your slides uh we
don't see any generative process in the
diagram so where does generative process
fit into this diagram or uh because the
way I see it uh I mean it's basically
somehow included in the generator model
or uh I don't know what is the the
distinction between these two concepts
so um you'll have to forgive some of our
the earlier literature uh for this
there's some terminological
inconsistency uh the only two constructs
that are at play here are the generative
model and the variational density that's
encoded by internal States that's it
um so the it is not the case that the
FTP is about how the generative model
models the generative process the a lot
of this language comes from uh you know
previous Bayesian approaches and in
particular the helmholtz machine in the
helmholtz machine uh so helmholtz
machines are some of the earlier
predictive coding machines and then the
helmholtz machine basically you have a
forward pass that connects the sensory
end to this leave the top of the
predictive hierarchy and then a
backwards pass connecting it uh the uh
you know the the uh the like top of the
model back to the sensory end and in in
a home holds machine you would call the
forward pass a recognition model or uh
and the backwards passage generative
model right the forwards pass is a
recognition model because you're
inputting some data and then basically
the by the time the information trickles
up to the top you have recognized what
caused the data and the backwards pass
is called a generative model for the the
reasons that are sometimes invoked in
the predictive coding literature uh
where you know you're basically uh
generating possible sensoria given a
certain configuration of States uh so
the we don't use the recognition and
generative in that sense anymore
um and you know I apologize in some
previous Publications I I've been a bit
sloppy in the way that I use my language
and I'd use the term recognition density
what's really at stake is uh and I'll
share my screen uh this to uh
yeah the help make the point uh that's
what it says here
so you have a you have your generative
model right your generative model is a
joint probability density so what is a
joint probability density uh well you
have a bunch of different uh basically
states that your your system uh is
defined over
um and you have a probability density uh
that the shape of which captures the way
that uh dates can change over time right
so like if I change this way then you
know I need to change in that way and
that's what this shape encodes
um and uh what the Feb says is if my
generative model has a certain
sparseness right if it has Markov
blankets then there's this additional
probability density that I can Define uh
it is parametrized by the internal
states of the system
and it's called the variational density
and this is like my probabilistic best
guess about what's causing my external
States
um at no point do you need to appeal to
any other bits of like yeah so
generative process when you're actually
coding these models up in Matlab or in
Python what we call the generative
process is just the equations of motion
that govern external States
so if you actually hand code one of
these one day your generative process
might include like Newtonian physics and
whatever else it's sort of just like
what is the process that actually
animates the Dynamics of external States
um in in some there in some very simple
models like in the uh the ones used by
Miguel Aguilera and colleagues you're
looking at
um linear dissipative systems and they
don't have any Dynamics right like so
basically the the system kind of just it
dissipates it's this a linear
dissertative system is a damped in
Spring physically right so it just goes
bring and then it dissipates to the
fixed point so similarly uh you may or
may not have Dynamics to the external
States and that's what gets harnessed in
the generative process uh yeah this
should be clear yeah sorry man no I mean
I think what the question that Ali is
asking also has some
important
um
correlates that often get asked to us
like what's the difference between
Consciousness or Dreaming or what's the
difference between a dead system that
decays or uh being uh psychotic
um and I think what Max was saying is
our system currently doesn't say
anything about your actual connection to
the real world other than a thing which
is successful at being a thing is
probably well uh joined relative to its
needs to the world and therefore
um your relation to reality is probably
um has probably got a better grasp if
you are functional for a longer longer
amount of time
this minus senescence
um so yeah does that kind of
yes
yes thank you thank you both uh it it
really makes a lot more sense now thank
you so much
well uh it's my pleasure and remember
like model just means joint probability
density here right so uh
there's a a
criminally underappreciated paper that
Carl wrote uh in entropy in 2012 called
the free energy principle for biological
systems uh which is where a lot of them
are called blanket story comes from and
in that paper Carl refers to the
generative model as just a generative
density so it's basically saying there's
a there's a underlying probability
density it describes the way that the
Dynamics are just are being generated
just generally uh and yeah and then you
have the uh if if that density has the
appropriate structure meaning if it has
like zeros in the right places uh then
you can Define this this other tracking
density uh that approximates the
generative
um model or density
and I also have a follow-up question
which I'll ask after that Samuel and
thales
okay uh thanks uh for the excellent talk
uh
uh I'm a professor at the State
University of Minnesota
uh I'm a philosopher cognitive
scientists psychologists
so
I worked mainly on reasoning but
by reading your paper what strikes me as
most promising
is
the possibility of solving the the hard
problem of Consciousness if if this goes
right and progressing means this model
but maybe an important part of that
depends on exactly what is meant by
Holograms and exactly
what this brings into a a theory as an
explanation right so
doing your presentation you were talking
something about that there's a
difference between
holography in the sense of bringing
light to something to make a projection
uh but you said that might be related as
well so I'm quite curious about these
how to use this this concept and how to
understand it uh in a more
Soul psychology sense
and also like
where it comes from because I'm not a
physicist so does it have does it depend
on string theory to to
to be correct
could you dive in a little more on this
concept first
now I think this is more a you question
Theory so basically
remember Maxwell really gave a good
explanation I kind of thought I had to
answer your question but I'm gonna give
a little bit so the boundary between any
two mutually separation systems A and B
is the holographic screen that encodes
like the eigenvalues of the interaction
that couples A and B so uh this is very
similar to how a hologram encodes
information about 3D objects onto a 2d
surface
um so a hologram stores information
about the phase and the amplitude of
Lights reflected from an object
and this allows the Reconstruction of a
3D image from a 2d surface and so here
similarly the holographic screen uh
encodes information about A System's
interaction with its environment which
allows for the prediction and control of
the systems Behavior so does that yeah
but does does it maybe allow for the
creation of an image that's that's the
sort of question so this is yeah this is
where we're giving it some thought
actually so the creation of an image is
it's a complex idea because what's an
image right but effectively
um
there is some work being done into
information
geometry and how that may potentially
interact with matter uh in in order to
um
to to translate to transmit information
basically uh and so it's possible
that the Reconstruction of information
is done through Fields being changed
such that the modalities you have
through your senses such as sight
um hearing touch or relative to the way
that the information needs to be
transmitted in terms of amplitude and
um and velocity Etc which in effect
gives you something like light
um but that research is still relatively
um
early so yes it is promising it is
leading in that direction it's probably
one of the most interesting formalism
because it touches on the connection
between
um you know Dynamics matter and how
information
allows for matter to be organized
but all those pieces have been properly
being put together it is heading there
though
um I would just add um the so the
original monstrosity of a paper had a
section on uh yeah explaining where
qualia come from based on the
statistical patterns of the input but as
Mao said like it was very early work and
I mean the core model was more or less
developed so we decided to like spin
that out as a separate thing and then
develop you know the the inner con the
inner screen model of Consciousness per
se
um you know to flush out a little bit or
to add some flesh to what now it was uh
saying which was already pretty meaty as
it is
um so we we have you heard of these
experiments where they they take a
little uh
they take a little pad with little pins
on it and they basically reconstruct
well they they they plug a camera on
your head and they put the this little
pad on your tongue and if they blindfold
you and they they basically have you
navigate and the um the camera generates
a kind of um like grayscale
you know version of the image but with
the little pins in terms of like how far
they push in uh Samuel are you seeing
the image that I'm that I'm discussing
or so you have a little little pad it
has little pins that can push uh at
various depths and what what you can do
is basically translate the uh image from
the camera into a different uh array of
like assorted pins and so yeah you put
this on your tongue
and if you blindfold yourself then use
this camera for about 20 to 30 minutes
the brain eventually recognizes that oh
this is supposed to go to the visual
area and then then you start to see
through your tongue in some weird way
like the the the the body actually
recognizes the statistical frequencies
of the uh like of the pins actually
pushing onto your tongue and and this is
experience not um as like a a physical
sensation but actually visually like you
start to experience an impoverished
grayscale visual field just from the
sensations that are being fed to your
tongue which suggests that there's
something deeply in you know deep about
the statistical structures of the
signals that are being processed and the
way that the qualia show up in your
experience
um so uh yeah uh but this is still like
super far off in that I wouldn't I
wouldn't have the pretension to claim
that we've cracked or call you come from
just yet
yeah yeah
uh I get what you're saying now uh
different uh patterns can uh make
different quality that you don't need
like different Magics to to have
different quality but
yeah I was wondering how that related to
to the Holograms but okay it's something
in development as you as you're saying
maybe I should uh let someone go and
then I'll go back to these Consciousness
questions
sure so Alice
well thank you all it was a great
presentation and great test by the way
hi Max thank you hi everyone I'm sorry
you guys are facing like a black screen
right now my camera is off that's all
right okay so
um I'm an anthropologists during
psychologist so I'm kind of an outsider
in here I'm not from the active interest
lab too so
you know I I study it but I'm not a
specialist in it so my questions are
kind of Broad and they're actually
really really simple but I think that
I'm not allowed to make one question
right pero and then
right so um actually my first question
will be uh something that Maria was
talking about before
me started so um the Articles account
Consciousness is an attribute of things
that possesses and reducible Market
blanket right with active States
exerting for instance over external
Dynamics so when applying to the neural
uh
uh physiological experience of the human
brain talking about neuromodulatory
influence over neuronal Dynamics uh and
with that in mind I would like to know
that should actually speculate a little
bit on the implication of this
structures issue of Consciousness for
how it might emerge during infant or
field development
that's a great set of questions uh we
gave this talk um
uh I gave a version of this talk to
um Luis pasoa's group at the
neuroscience and philosophy salon and
Anna Shanika asked a similar question I
would um I don't know I mean Mao
probably has a better response I would
point you in the direction of the work
of Anna shaunika
um she has some really cool work on
co-embodiment and cohomeostasis and
pregnancy and this kind of thing
um I uh I confess that I need to think
about uh the way of it like because
presumably you could just continue
extending this outwards right so we've
talked about inner screens
and there's like an external screen but
presumably you could just reapply this
whole screen talk in the other direction
like on the other side uh yeah exactly
the first prior well the the first prior
is um one of those papers but she's got
like another a set of papers uh yeah it
might this might be it right um so one
thing to also know could consider is the
sparseness aspect of um of our model
so
um as you develop you prune connections
and you become more and more sparse
which gives you more
um
path approximations
to the way that information gets
agglomerated to form patterns that are
recognizable
and so perhaps this has something to do
with the emergence of a moment where
um you sort of come online because
there's something like an irreducible
markup blanket that emerges by virtue of
having pruned enough such that you can
now make sense of the stimuli
relative to some couplings in time
rather than just hungry you know like
there might be something
um to that effect however
um
we need to be careful again with infants
what we mean about Consciousness like do
you mean
um
selfhood do you mean the capacity to
reflect on self put or do you mean the
capacity to
um learn and act on the world which is
uh closer to where we're headed because
um while babies may not necessarily have
this capacity to reflect on their
selfhood right away they do have the
capacity to react to signals and act on
the signals in order to get to a point
where their preferred states are enacted
so babies hungry cries food comes so
there is a degree to which a baby much
like a cell has a degree of
Consciousness relative to our model
so I'd also point you in the direction
of uh Rosalind Moran's work on the Aging
brain
um she's got some cool work that
suggests that you're well the Precision
of our model increases over time uh
which has to do a little bit with you
know what what Mal was discussing
earlier
um we we know just from neuroanatomy
that uh the process of pruning brain
connections uh only accelerates uh
through time and basically that this
that means that you're disconnecting
certain things from certain others right
like expertise has more to do with
understanding what is what is not
connected to uh than understanding what
is connected to what
um and so uh yeah there is probably uh a
kind of Developmental course whereby the
model becomes sparser and sparser and
sparser and sparser and you know more
and more precise uh but uh you know this
is a very cool direction for exploration
uh I I don't know if I have anything
more cogent to say at this time about it
pleasure
so I know Ali wanted a second girl and
uh so did Samuel does anybody else have
other questions because no other hands
are raised at this time
oh okay so we have one more hand I think
uh
I know uh actually uh you basically
answered uh my other questions uh so
thank you so much
pleasure awesome so then uh Dallas has
his hand up again Maria says her hand up
and seminal has hand up so tell us first
I suppose
I don't know you guys like to I know
it's Maria first because they just you
know
and then sure go ahead Maria
all right so
um yeah I didn't say before but I am a
psychologist and master in philosophy
and now I'm doing PhD in philosophy as
well and it's not really a question I I
would just like to to understand better
what
what is
memory in your in your inner mother
because uh I understand the the
information passing and the the middle
uh layers or levels that contains
information but uh how exactly do we
construct for for example The Narrative
self or something that we remember uh
from a long time or episodic memory I
mean I didn't understand it very well in
in the paper so if you could just shout
something it's a uh it's a it's a
computer science processing uh example
information processing notion of memory
um so uh you get some data and you need
to parse it
right into things that are causing that
data well presumably you need to
leverage some beliefs or you know
knowledge about how to parse that data
and that that comes in the form of
information basically uh yeah uh you
need to uh you know have some capacity
to reduce the entropy of your
observations and to kind of carve things
out into things and the inner screen
serves as the locus where the
information is encoded so that's the
cool thing about uh the quantum version
of the uh markdown blanket formulation
it tells you uh where all of the
information that characterizes the
coupling across you know two bulks it
where it lives basically I mean to get a
little bit more technical the the Markov
blanket itself is constituted by the
degrees of freedom the couple the two
systems uh together
um and yeah if you uh you can think of
this as an array of bits that answer yes
no questions about are the are the two
systems communicating across this
channel uh yes or no and in some sense
the state of the blanket at any given
time uh it gives you all of the
information that you need to
characterize the coupling uh in terms of
these yes no questions so all of the
classical information that you need to
characterize the coupling lives on the
blanket and
um yeah having an internal blanket means
that you can have an internal store of
such answers to yes no questions that
you can then use to parse the sensory
stream uh but in a in a kind of standard
computer architecture it's just saying
that you have a memory register right
that you know so you yeah you need you
need to store some of the information
that you're processing somewhere so that
you can deploy it and the idea is that
it lives on this internal screen
does that help and in this case it would
be the hypocampus
uh yeah and all well all of the inner
screens in code information in this
sense right the the point of having an
inner screen structure at all is to kind
of retain information to parse your uh
your sensory stream and yeah structures
like the hippocampus like these upper uh
brain stem structures or what used to be
called the limbic brain and so on we
think that these are all at the top the
idea right is that like so you have your
sensory motor end then you have your
prefrontal cortex which is the
controller for the pre for the sensory
motor and it's a controller in the sense
that its main function is to inhibit
activity in the sensory motor area but
um if if uh if the main function of
prefrontal Cortex is to go to the rest
of the brain then there is also a part
of the brain whose main function it is
to go to the prefrontal cortex and that
is these are these upper regions that
we're describing
um so yeah I the memory register is like
live in this whole stack
ultimately uh like the point about
memory is less unique to this Apex
structure what is unique to these top
structures though is the re the right
only kind of directionality that they
that they don't have any context right
like there there is no higher structure
that can provide memory to these uh top
layers so all they can do is act right
and and in particular they act in a kind
of covert Fashion on other layers of uh
the brain uh I think would be the
answer to that now did you want to add
anything to that
there's a
so you touched on the notion of selfhood
and how the narrative cell unfolds over
time and leverages memory
and our model basically established it
with self-hood the process of selfing is
because according to our model and very
uh like sorry I'm sick
uh very like
um Thomas metzinger's model of Southwood
it's a process not a thing so selfing is
the process by which the internal states
are capable of
mapping to the relevant external states
such that they can act in such a way as
to fulfill their own needs this is also
very close to what Neil Seth about says
about the beast machine
um and so if you have nested structure
in each of these nested structure has a
time scale say so you have structures
that are that happen on the milliseconds
and sometimes scales that happen on
um this the scale of a sentence and then
some structures that track much longer
time scales like your life goals and uh
and in your ancestry and stuff like that
um you find that
memory is just the story The binning of
the relevant information at the time
scale at which it is relevant and so you
can retrieve the relevant information
for the shorter time scales because it
acts as a prior for that for the lower
time scale does that help for the
narrative so yes all right thank you
awesome
um
sir go ahead
yeah
about the uh going back to the band
psychism problem uh in how you described
consciousness
I think it's
very well
uh
I mean it's old in the literature that
you can have information processing
which is not
uh
conscious but it's mental in some sense
in other animals or other or the beings
which are not biological beings
and but when you describe your models I
know you have this level also but you
also have a level of phenomenal
awareness or phenomenal phenomenal
Consciousness which you you are
describing
and
I think that's the most
particularly important part of the the
model the phenomenal awareness part
and
it's the model is the part of the model
that can contribute to something new to
me in in a sense that wasn't described
so I'm glad you mentioned matzinger
because Metzger is one of the few who
have described Consciousness as a
virtual reality
um
and what I think is interesting about
describing Consciousness as a virtual
reality is that is that it makes a
difference between mental information
processing or unconscious information
processes in those processes that are
conscious because they are simulated
somehow uh
so an interesting thing of having a
different language
to speak of conscious events is that we
can then explain
why they are different and
we can explain
why we have images in our head and stuff
like that and why these images seem to
have
causal
Powers if if they have at all so
when I imagine something you can make my
my hand move or something like that
and
you can describe this only with
electrical information or something like
that
but
it doesn't explain why we have different
information processes with
Consciousness and those without
Consciousness and I know all Theory Of
Consciousness have a a distinction
between the unconscious and the
conscious level but adding something
like the metaphysics or virtual reality
would explain the metaphysics of
conversation for instance if you're
playing a video game
does the
the content of that game
matter
fertilization or is it just the
information that stored in the computer
that matters
I mean there's a a
variable there which means a sword does
it meaning a sword make any difference
at all
and I think that's something that hasn't
been very much discussed in philosophy
so David Chalmers has just written a
book
recently about virtual reality
but it doesn't it doesn't apply to to
Consciousness yet and
I think if you guys find something
uh in physics that's different
as as you guys are trying to do is you
admitted having that aim then maybe
there could be some sort of
a different physical explanation to
conscious causation so I would like you
guys to comment on that that's really
interesting we um we draw on medzinger's
uh work on opacity and transparency
um so you know in medzinger's work just
for the audience uh there are two kinds
of cognitive processes there are
transparent processes uh that we are not
aware of as cognitive processes per se
um and then there are opaque processes
uh which we are so for instance uh the
the metaphor comes from uh you know
trans a transparent or opaque window uh
and most of the time the window just
lets you see through it towards uh
whatever is on the other side but
sometimes it's a bit grimy and then you
see the window itself and so uh you know
similarly there are some processes that
mainly deliver things in the world and
then there are other processes that
deliver mental processes to us uh as as
kind of the object of our perception uh
in some sense uh so these um these are
processes like attention uh or like
paying uh attentional like processing or
paying attention to your own attentional
State uh these uh processes uh make
other processes opaque
um Terence Deacon uh the Anthropologist
also talks about similar phenomena in
terms of like absence absence and what
he calls absential phenomena so there's
a sense in which this top layer
what it does is Implement uh
opacification
so the the top layer can only be about
other layers in the stack and uh this
kind of reversal of the flow of
information is that we think like the
the key to understanding the way that uh
like mental processes are made available
for introspection at all
um yeah so uh that's that's how I would
respond uh Mao I saw you turn your
camera on uh do you have morta no no no
I don't have more to answer that
question
cool
um so
tell us you have another question
yep
so um I know guys ever really discussed
some of this before special on Twitter
um but it can just like repeat it
um because if I understood it right when
applying the model to human neurobiology
the article kind of sections
Central neural system
could you repeat the last thing you
broke you broke up pretty bad sorry my
laptop is really really interesting so
okay um the article seems to align
itself to a more modular account of the
central nervous system
um but in contrast to motor accounts
that some you know dynamicon distributed
approaches that suggests that there are
no parts of the brain with the Decay
functions right
um but regions with various capacities
that have expressed in software
assembled test specific collisions so
this correlation sometimes are termed
like transiently assembled local
neuronal subsystems right like yeah
we're big fans of like big families yeah
exactly so uh this approaches the
specialism is only a functional
Footprints and brain functions and I've
heard the result if you should fix it
networks implementing specific processes
but the result of high order relations
between regions so my question bear in
mind knowing that you guys know this
kind of approaches right
um do I think that the level VR
construction viable model could be cash
out in terms of transient correlations
built on the flight such as following
towns yes I mean we have a paper doing
that uh from 2020 it's called neural and
phenotypic representations uh under the
free energy principle and it is uh one
of our lesser known
um
uh papers let me just put it in the chat
quickly
um and so what we show in this paper is
that it's possible to simulate the form
the transient formation of Markov
blankets
um that basically track stimulus
features uh so uh there are a lot of
moving parts to what you were saying on
the one hand yes uh you can totally use
the Markov blanket formalism to model
the transient formation and assembly of
these
um I would also add that there's this
there's a new uh perspective on
modularity that opens up via the free
energy principle
um the it's it's best explored in this
paper by Thomas par inesh ippolito and a
few others called modules or mean Fields
where uh the argument uh and again this
dovetails nicely with what Mike Anderson
and his group are doing currently
um the argument is that uh the
specialization of brain regions is not
functional uh it's computational and
this is effectively what Mike Anderson
and Company are arguing is that like
each each patch of the brain is
specialized in converting certain
patterns into other patterns it's not
like you have you know a visual region
or uh you know I think Mike's example is
the Broca's area which is associated
with the production of language is
actually activated in more
non-linguistic tasks than in linguistic
tasks so what that suggests is that each
brain area is kind of like contributing
certain stereotyped forms of computation
to the overall process that's uh
unfolding in the brain
um and in the 300 energy principle
literature you can understand that as a
kind of factorization right so what and
where we have two different streams in
the brain the dorsal and the ventral uh
which respect which are handled the what
I am seeing and where I am seeing and
basically the the idea is that this uh
anatomical segregation of Pathways
corresponds to a factorization and
inference where you are and what you are
are independent you could be here you
could be here uh and there yeah so uh I
think I've tried to yeah
so that was a really good answer I'm
going to try and say it a little bit
differently and see uh see what sticks
to the wall
um so
each hierarchical level of the brain has
its like has Mark of blankets right so
it's remember these things are nested
um and they exchange with other levels
according to the dependency structures
of the mark of blankets
um and so this is like hierarchical
predictive coding right so ascending
prediction errors can be read as active
States well descending can constitute
sensory States from the point of view of
a given level
um so using this factorization the
Maxwell just mention some brain regions
become specialized to encode distinct
probability factors that are
statistically independent and uh this
creates a sort of physiological
separation of brain regions which imply
that the the the information encoded in
these regions is conditionally
independent of that encoded in other
distinct regions uh so it allows for the
formation of new functions as the brain
regions interact
uh so we get to the point of mental
action this is enabled by the existence
of a subsystem
that is both
um
irreducible so there exists no further
Mark of blanket partitions of the
internal States and complex or
expressive enough to act like a suitably
flexible uh matter controller
so this matter controller coordinates
overt and covert action that's the last
part of what Maxwell explained which can
be seen as trans as forming transient
connections right so it that's the point
of precision uh Wayne
so the next the nested scales of
increasingly large ensembles of neurons
basically form
um coherently and so they also have
their own Mark of blankets
so we can generalize to different nested
connectivity structures in the brain
where we find uh
formally identical patterns at
subordinate levels and superordinate
skills
so does that
help restructure what Maxwell said
basically
yes yes it did awesome awesome
um so
several still has his hand up I think
Ali also has his hand up
um Ali didn't go yet Samuel do you mind
if Ali goes first
sure go ahead
uh thank you yeah I just wanted to
make a couple of comments about
the notion of self
self-everancing or self-modeling that's
just been discussed because
uh you see sometimes in philosophical
literature the sensibility of secondary
properties are usually uh they're
divided into the sensibility of things
in itself and Sensibility of things form
itself
and but under these conditions some
philosophers believe that real sensation
would not be possible or as Arthur rimbo
uh famously put it I
is an other right but in some recent
developments particularly in process
materialism
through the work of people like Thomas
nail the Manuel delanda and Karen broad
they've tried to somehow overcome this
issue this philosophical distinction
between in itself and For Itself by
introducing the notion of
self-receptivity uh name or in other
words a capacity to be affected and to
affect at the same time because uh by
introducing a self-receptivity then the
the sensation of each sensed point in
the flow can become itself as an other
to itself so basically that distinction
between in itself and for itself would
be dismantled effectively and that uh
what that's why it can
provide a more reliable way to discuss
the notion of real sensation or real
even subjectivity as a flow that just
falls on itself and comprises both in
itself and by itself and uh that's also
why I believe
um fep and the active inference can
provide uh even on the uh I mean more
philosophical note uh more a reliable
way to talk about what it means to uh to
sense and be sensed at the same time
I mean I I I find that very compelling I
know you and Mao have been working
together so I think Mao might have
something more insightful than I I think
that's great though
I agree nice
I agree
um
I think I like linking these ideas to
what we wrote in the Consciousness text
by basically saying that
um
bigger screen is the folding onto itself
right it's it can be seen as a as the
wrapping inside another form the
Consciousness is right into the form is
wrapped in the form of the mind
um
and so you can if you partition internal
and external States and the market
blankets has these different kind of
active and uh sensory States
um
you can see how the folding basically
happens through this Loop uh that is
it isn't necessarily
happening because it's not only
happening at one scale does not have to
be non-simultaneous like we we consider
that uh that these things are
um separated at times simply because uh
we're thinking of one time scale
um but so if we if we add this notion of
interaction
um we can highlight the dynamic and
relational nature of Consciousness
um to refer to the process where the
agent and its environment actively shape
one another
um
so the Mind creating an inner screen
here just reflects its understanding of
the world and of itself through like
basically of the world through its own
filter and the filter is replica
reflection of itself it's just that
effectively if there are errors you need
to be able to model
what parts of
your filter
created potentially the error
um
so yeah
um you can yeah does that does that help
kind of flesh out this idea of holding
onto itself and incoming sensory data
I think this question was for Ali or
Maxwell
so one of you has to decide whether I I
thought it was for Ali that was great
okay cool
hahaha
yeah that was great thanks
awesome so Samuel I think you have a
question
yes
my final questions so
yeah I was mostly talking about the
heart problems courses because I I also
buy the predictive processing story and
I use what you guys are saying
uh but one issue that I have with the
productive process in the story is that
uh
we can apply it to explanations in
various ways so it's sometimes like
sometimes you can it seems you can tell
any story
with the same Theory and it's hard to
know which one is true if you can tell
multiple stories
so I think that's a problem with um
predictive processing in general and you
can explain for instance for instance
autism in different ways and I think
people have described that
um
your model
unconsciousness
how can we know that any of that is true
how empirical is it and during the talk
you guys mentioned something that you
were gonna test something
based on this which was very uh
promising and I'd like you to comment on
that so Maxwell has a really
he has a really cool paper on the map
territory fantasy fallacy which I think
is part of the answer here and we've
also written some uh so I'll let Maxwell
dig into it probably was going to be a
very flesh out answer so I'll give a
very small answer which he's going to
blow out of the water afterwards but
um
there are some things we can do to test
whether the predictions made by our
model actually come to fruition
um so that's that's one way to to test
the the empirical validity of a model
but to keep in mind a model logistic
model and so since you have multiple
realizability effectively what really
only matters is whether your model
actually has any predictive power
um so here let's say that we can
um examine whether the brain structure
and function reflects the nested and
hierarchical organization which is
predicted by our model
or whether intervention that alter the
brain structure or function lead to
changes in conscious experience as we
predicted
um or for instance we can test which
parts of the brain relate to which scale
of elements that are perceived and then
make predictions about the contents of
Consciousness and their neural
correlates to see how well it Maps so
these are things that we could
empirically test
I'll I'll just add a bit of meta flavor
to that
um so remember I started with the
distinction between Dynamics mechanics
and principles personally I don't like
the verbiage of predictive processing I
don't think it's a I don't think frankly
I don't think the term refers to
anything specific uh when people use the
term rigorously so
Andy Clark introduced the term in his
2013 paper whatever next because he
wanted to talk about some broad kind of
approach predict prediction involving
approach to explaining cognition but at
the time he he didn't want to commit to
any specific implementation of the idea
so uh he was like here's predictive
coding he was hierarchical predictive
coding but as I'm sure you know
predictive coding makes very specific
predictions about the neural
implementation of the theory so in
particular predictive coding assumes
that there are distinct neuronal
subpopulations that encode the error and
the prediction error he didn't
necessarily want to commit to one
version of that because who knows maybe
it's the same subpopulations that you
know issue predictions and prediction
errors at different times and you have
some kind of like time-based like rate
coding or whatever uh going on
um he also at the time didn't want to
commit to the free energy principle per
se so you know I think
yeah uh if the predictive processing
doesn't really denote a specific Theory
and one of the problems that emerged uh
is you know there's a whole bunch of
literature uh presenting accounts that
are consistent with predictive
processing which doesn't mean anything
really uh it just means hey you can kind
of wave your hands around and this kind
of looks like a prediction if you kind
of you know look at it the right way
um I think the more rigorous way to
understand this is to bring it back to
the math and say that there are
principles uh mechanics and Dynamics so
there's some uh phenomenon that we want
to explain we have a formal description
of it this might be like a you know a
data set or whatever else describing
like the actual values of whatever
system you're considering
the free energy principle
um is deployed to construct specific
generative models uh which provide you
with the equations of motion that
explain that behavior right so the
generative model is I mean in effect a
set of linked equations of motions that
you see here with these dependence
relationships
um and uh yeah so when you actually
commit to a specific generative model
then you are in a Terrain where you can
bring empirical evidence to the to to
kind of decide uh validate or to falsify
the model so uh like I would draw your
attention to you know the the free
energy principle uh we know the free
energy principle is true for
mathematical reasons it would be as
silly to try to invalidate the fep
empirically as it would be to try to you
know falsify calculus by trying to
observe some phenomenon in the empirical
world it is true mathematically
and then you use that principle to
derive specific models which are then
testable uh so I don't I don't know if
we've gone all the way here uh so this
is somewhere still kind of in between an
in-principle explanation and a specific
model
um to get to more fleshed out empirical
predictions of the sort that Mao is
discussing we would have to get a bit
more specific which we're doing kind of
in parallel I I don't feel ready to
discuss the exact predictions and the
ways that we'll be um discussing them
this is uh or exploring them testing
them this is very much work in progress
I can tell you it'll involve
psychedelics
but uh that uh that's pretty much uh
where I'm coming I'm not comfortable
extending any more than that I feel like
I might expose a flank that's not ready
to be exposed
perfect thanks for that
pleasure
um and that brings us to the uh and uh
oh uh tell us you have your hand up
again uh do you wanna
hop on who has time
yeah yeah I think we'll have fun for one
more question yeah but Daniel you want
to ask something because whatever that's
two times
so okay um actually
I would like for guys to delve a little
bit deeper and the implications of
Maria's first question it's the other
side of the Quan
um related to the pen photo open cycle
stuff the population level conscious or
conscious processes in
complex organisms sharing a phenotype
for example like ant colonies or no more
speculative sense
um like
um complex organisms
um aligned and shared like a distributed
um generative model in Niche building
processes right so as Maxwell once said
the other side of the
um Metro selection
right process so
um given the sparsity and given the
transient you know
um conversions
that these populations are in this
specific moment specific process can we
speculate something about conscious in
this level
thank you
all right I think Maxwell is uh staying
quiet because he expects me to sort of
started answering the question correct
so um we've done a lot of work in
simulating large-scale systems right uh
so we've simulated uh Niche uh We've
simulated interaction between one and
two or more actors uh what it means for
belief sharing propagation the formation
of Market blankets Etc and so
um I think the key the true question
would be how transients are the market
blankets at the level of superstructures
and how does it enable those structures
to be able to encode
um
information at the level of the
interaction between different scales so
I do think that given our model you can
assume that a system is conscious by
virtue of having nested Parts which can
read and write where superordinates
entity or level of the the structure is
right only and the lower level is also
right only and through this um this sort
of boundary of the entity and the
interactions between the parts of the
entity you have what resembles a
conscious process at which you have some
degree of perception
um the real the really interesting
question there becomes what becomes the
irreducible parts so if you could be
understood a little bit like a cell if
you as a human your irreducibility is
that your cell as a part of a larger
system yeah
where what's experiences at the uh at
the system level uh and I think that's a
really truly interesting question if we
look at ants for instance
um
ants on their own don't do much
competition right but ends as a hive
then become much more interesting and
they behave uh in a coordinated fashion
which can look as if they were making
much more complex computation and you
could say the same for yourselves your
cells in themselves they have a very
simple uh process very simple
computation but
together through these large-scale
emerging coordinating patterns some of
them become your skin some of them
become your brain uh and the in the the
conscious part that you are experiencing
at the scale at which you can understand
Consciousness currently
um that's where most information most
information is lost such that the
irreducible part of your Consciousness
is the parts that can become opaque
um so
I think I've answered most of your
question
now I would uh maybe just add the like
so uh this is a uh not fully chartered
territory and I think there may be some
uh agreements and disagreements I am I'm
always
um wary of the intentional
misattribution fallacy uh where uh you
know we attribute uh intentionality or
mental properties to uh things that
don't end up having them I think that
the kind of minimal
um
the kind of minimal intentionality pen
intentionalism pen representationalism
whatever you want to call it that
follows from the free energy principle
uh gets you uh a lot of the intelligent
looking Behavior without having to pause
it that there's actually something it's
like to be you know a city uh or
whatever what makes me skeptical of the
idea that there is such a thing is that
uh what what we are suggesting is that
what's necessary for Consciousness in
the stronger kind of agential sense is
an external Markov blanket that
insulates a bunch of internal States and
then these internal States in turn have
this kind of nested structure uh and
that's what I don't think that there is
in say like a city or uh like a higher
order kind of cultural I'd have to think
about this so this is you're kind of
pushing at the limits of where I'm
comfortable thinking which is
appreciated by the way thank you for the
challenge questions
yeah but I think there's room for
disagreement and I might be wrong about
this uh I don't think we just have to
keep pushing to find out who's correct
uh but I find what mala said uh
interesting and compelling and
intriguing I I am just like you know
intellectually conservative at this
point in my life being an old man
this is this is where I think it's a
little bit complicated to fully answer
that question because we we have
metaphorical tools but we don't have
anything ready yet to go any any any
further
um one thing that I like to think about
is
the only way you're ever going to
experience maybe what it's like to be
part of a Consciousness which is
entailed by
something more than you
um is having connection to sort of hyper
feed hive mind thing uh and being kind
of pushed and pulled so if you've ever
been part of like what a mob uh or if
you are on Twitter and you see people
um piling onto something and then you
talk to them and and they're like I
don't
I kind of blacked out I don't know what
happened because you you can't at this
at this part of the hierarchy compute
the entirety of what happened all you
can do is understand sort of your path
that was part of a larger network of web
of paths which themselves
um given the priors of the
superstructures you're embedded in are
kind of sort of going somewhere and
represent the
the error push of all the people that
share a similar type of model that
therefore constitutes a cultural
Direction uh so that's that's the best
way I think we can understand like hyper
priors as a function of what it might be
like to be a city sort of thing but
that's that's as far as I I can take
this metaphor for now
awesome
does anyone want to give a final thought
otherwise I'll just list just a few
points that I found really cool about
the discussion of kind of places it
takes us at the end but anyone else I
just want to say the the hard problem is
really hard and it's called like that
for a reason so uh like we were I think
we're you know hopefully moving in in
the direction of making this lesson
serious but uh like all of this should
be taken as very preliminary
investigations really trying to sketch
out the Bare Bones of an explanation
um and yeah there is far more work ahead
of us than uh behind us I think
um now any final thoughts
um I like to think about it in the
opposite terms
in terms of like the future of evolution
can be understood through like what it's
like to have language and what it's like
to have
um larger scale cognition and therefore
uh yes of course this is very
preliminary research but it's cool to
dream
awesome any guess Maria Samuel Ollie
feels
so any prediction on whether when the
other two proofreads will come out I'm
really interested in it
so the uh God you know inshallah the um
the mum paper will be released early
July
um right now reasonably
um and then the other one is has to do
with uh yeah extending outwards and that
might be like another year like I don't
think I don't think that's that's coming
soon
um but hopefully revisions to the this
uh paper will be coming out also over
the summer
um and yeah I would anticipate July
um
hopefully we'll we'll see there's a lot
going on right now so
awesome all right I'll just oh say no
please first
no I just want to say thank you to
everyone and for answering my questions
and yeah thanks
well thank you for your attention uh
your kind comments and your interest uh
it was really fun to discuss and I think
you asked a lot of important questions
bills
eventually or anyone else
uh yeah I
I also wanted to
uh thank you so much for having I mean
uh I know that these kinds of
discussions can have uh I mean lots of
implications in many many other areas
but it was really Illuminating and
clarifying so
you're too kind my friend uh thank you
very much
um yeah this has been fun
genuinely
awesome all right I'll just give a few a
few comments
all right so first yes congratulations
to all for the recent papers it's really
exciting to see a kind of Continuum and
integration with all these different
threads
um the way that we think of physics and
physics of information
and the history and the philosophy of
the physics of information that kind of
a gradient might be reimagined such that
there's a clearer understanding of when
it's the firmware or the kernel of in
the tradition of as I see you at all
writing sometimes in versus
interpretations and and that's maybe
situational but that's a gray area
um reminds me of the instrumentalist
realism debates of 2021 your with the
map of the territory which has been
developed out so much further and just
the ability especially in a situation in
a model specific way to separate out the
intelligence or information structure or
the behavior from any kind of qualia
type discussion
um the recent
developments with uh Chris fields at all
and the waste energy and where free
energy goes and the kind of
saying like one has forgotten more than
someone else has learned so just the
idea that to have awareness there has to
be that discardle and then that might be
related to the irreversibility and the
time Consciousness that also you've been
uh developing
the eco-evo Devo components and just
multi-scale biology connecting it to
traditions of thought and work in
biology which is big but that's kind of
how we retro grandparent back into
biology promisingly with the ways that
multi-sale systems are already
considered and then also just the recent
developments in category Theory and the
Primacy of the relational and the
physics as information processing and
then the way that that enables very
knowledgeable individuals like you all
to come from a lot of the philosophy and
the history and all these other threads
to come together with the actual
modeling
in a very satisfying way so thank you
all for the stream and really looking
forward to the next steps
bye thank you bye-bye
thanks